hey this is pressure Walker reminding
you to mind your decisions what is the
value of the following series the first
term is 1 all over 1 plus the square
root of 2 the next term is 1 over the
quantity square root of 2 plus square
root of 3 the next term is 1 over the
square root of 3 plus the square root of
4 and this continues until we have 1
over the square root of 2016 plus the
square root of 2017 you have to solve
this in five minutes and you cannot use
a calculator this problem was given to
14 year-olds in Hong Kong and I think
Yale for suggesting it pause the video
if you'd like to give it a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
we're going to solve this problem using
a useful formula called the difference
of squares here's why this formula is
true start out with one square with an
area of a squared and another square
with an area of B squared if we subtract
the area of B squared from a squared we
have the following shape we can now
dissect this shape into different
rectangles and we'll connect sides of
equal length the a minus B sides will
connect together the resulting shape is
a rectangle where one side is a plus B
and the other side is a minus B thus we
have the formula a squared minus B
squared is equal to a plus B multiplied
by a minus B so how does it help us
solve this problem well take a look at
the series the very first term can be
re-written as 1 over the square root of
1 plus the square root of 2 so a general
term in the series will be 1 over the
square root of K plus the square root of
k plus 1 let's analyze this term first
I'll flip the two terms in the
denominator now we'll multiply both the
numerator and denominator by the square
root of K plus 1 minus the square root
of K if we multiply both the numerator
and denominator it's the same thing as
multiplying by 1 the numerator will
simplify to be the square root of K plus
1 minus the square root of K now the
denominator will be a difference of
squares here we have a plus B and here
we have a minus B thus the result will
be a squared minus B squared which
simplifies to be K plus 1 minus K the
terms K will cancel out and we're just
left with 1 thus we have the square root
of K plus 1 minus the square root of K
now this term which is equal to 1 just
vanishes and so we simplify our formula
like this we're going to flip the terms
because it'll be a little bit easier
down the line now let's take a look at
our series and we'll substitute in for
the first term we're going to end up
with
a square root of 1 plus the square root
of 2 the next term will be negative
square root of 2 plus the square root of
3 this pattern will continue and we keep
substituting what's the point of all
this well we're gonna get a magical
simplification notice this square root
of 2 minus square root of 2 will cancel
out then the square root of 3 minus
square root of 3 will cancel out and so
on and each of these terms will cancel
out the pattern is reminiscent of a
telescope and thus this is known as a
telescoping series when you retract the
telescope only the beginning and the end
remain similarly in this series it'll
contract to just the first term and the
very last term and so we simplify once
more negative square root of 1 will be
equal to negative 1 and then we flip the
terms and that's our answer this series
simplifies to be equal to the square
root of 2017 minus 1 amazing thanks for
watching and for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you